تصويت امامي بعد اسبوعين على استبعاد
ايران من هيئه المراه وجنرال يقر بمقتل
اكثر من 300 في المظاهرات
اجتماع للاليه الثلاثيه والسفراء العرب
بالخرطوم والسعوديه واكيد حرصها على
استقرار السودان
تنضم الى المؤهلين الى الدور الثاني فرنسا
والبرازيل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه النشره المفصله
تاتيكم من العربيه نشرت تلفزيوني ايراني
انترناشونال تسجيل صوتيا مسربا اجتماعي
مسؤولي الاعلام الرسميه الايرانيين مع
نائب قائدي منظمه البسيج قاسم قريشي وذلك
عقب اختراق وكاله انباء فارس
الحرس الثوري مسؤول الاعلام الرسميه
اعربوا عن قلقه من ارهاق قوه الامن على
خلفيه قمع الاحتجاجات واضراب التجار في
اثنين او اثنين و20
والسلام معدل اغلاق الاسواق في الخامس عشر
من نوفمبر من 70 الى 100% وسجل طهران اكبر
نسبه من اغلاق الاسواق وذكر المسؤولون
الايرانيون في الاجتماع ان طلاب تجمعهم في
اثنتين والستين جامعه وكليه واضربوا عن
الدراسه في 11 جامعه وقال احد مسؤوله
وسائل الاعلام ان هناك اثنتين 10 حاله
هجوم
ومكاتب ممثلين المرشد في
اعدتي مدن
اعترف الجنرال الايراني امير علي صدق قائد
القوات الجويه في الحرس التوريبي مقتل
اكثر من 300 شخص في التظاهرات والاحتجاجات
المستمره في مختلفه انحاء البلاد منذ
شهرين لكن هذه الحصيله الرسميه تقل بكثير
عن الحصيله التي اعلنتها منظمه نشطاء حقوق
الانسان في ايران وتقول هذه المنظمه ان
451 محتجا و60 من قوه الامن قوات الامود
بدا الاضطرابات كما اعتقل اكثر من 80
10,000 شخص
يصوت المجلس الاقتصادي والاجتماعي التابعه
للامم المتحده منتصف شهر ديسمبر المقبل
على مشروع قرار امريكي لاستبعاد ايران من
هيئه الامم المتحده المعنيه بالمساواه بين
الجنسين وتمكين المراه مشروع القرار
الامريكيه يهدف لمعاقبه ايران بسبب
حرمانها للنساء من حقوقهن وقمعها الوحشي
للاحتجاجات حيث واشار مسؤول اممي خلال
تصريحات لوكاله رويترز الى ان الولايات
المتحده على وجهه حشد الدعم اللازم لاخراج
ايران من الهيئه الامميه
قال رئيس الاوكرانيين
القوات الروسيه قصفت 30 منطقه في اقليم
خرسان
258 مره الاسبوع الماضي فاقد انسحبت
القوات الروسيه
هذا الشهر
قال وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني ان بلاده
بحاجه الى محولات الكهربائيه ودفاعات جويه
محسنه ليسدد ضربات الجويه الروسيه على
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه وجاءت مطالب قريبه
خلال لقاء بمسؤولين من استونيا وفنلندا
وايسلندا
قبل اجتماع وزراء خارجيه حلف شمال الاطلسي
في بوخارست يوم عيد الثلاثاء والاربعاء
بينما تتواصل تتواصل الازمه الاوكرانيه
الروسيه تتفاقم ازمه الامن الغذائي في
العديد من الدول الافريقيه من بينها
اثيوبيا ما جعلها تعمل بخطوه للاعتماد على
نفسها وتوفير الغذائي لاكثر من مئه مليون
يوبي
انتاج القمح في اثيوبيا خطوه تسعى فيها
اثيوبيا لتخفيف ازمه واردات القمح جر
الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه عبر تعزيز
الانتاج المحلي وتقليل الاعتماد على
الاستيراد خطوه غير تركيبه المحاصيل
الزراعيه في اثيوبيا من خلال انتاج مليوني
طن من القمح بميزانيه تقارب المئتين مليون
دولار لضمان امنها الغذائي وبحثا عن
الاكتفاء الذاتي
من زراعيا جيدا واستطعنا انهول السوق
المحلي بمنتجاتنا المحليه الوفيره ويمكن
القول ان هذا العام كان مختلفا عن سابقه
بمجنينه من محصول
الامدادات القادمه من الخارج وتعدد
السياسات الاقتصاديه ترى الحكومه ان كميه
الامطار الكبيره التي هطلت على اثيوبيا
هذا العام استطاعت ان تنعش الز بشكل ملحوظ
مما سيساهم في سد الفجوه بين الاستهلاك
والانتاج المحلي وتامين المخزون
الاستراتيجي اللازمي لتحقيق حلم قديم
وتحديه الجفاف الذي ضرب المنطقه
الروسيه عانينه من توفير الحبوب الغذائيه
اللازمه في بلادنا رغم عدم توفر العمله
الصعبه الكافيه ومن خلال جهودنا المحليه
استطعنا ان نوفر انتاجا كبيرا لسد الفجر
مستغلينه طول الامطار الكثيفه خلال الفتره
الماضيه
الاثيوبيه حمايه المنتج المحلي عبر تقليل
دخول المحاصيل المستورده وزياده انتاج
المحاصيل المحليه لتشكيل حصانه داخليه
لمواجهه ازمه الغذاء العالميه من خلال
انتاج 10 ملايين قنطار حيث ان يبدا تستورد
17 مليون قنطار سنويا مما ادى الى تقليص
الفارق في الطلب الخارجي للقمح وساعد في
تعزيز الميزان التجاري والتشجيع على
الاكتفاء الذاتي ومن ثم الاتجاه نحو
امكانيه التصدير بعد توفير اكثر من 60% من
الاستهلاك السنوي للبلاد والذي يقدر
بثلاثه فاصله تسعه مليون طن من القمح مع
استمرار الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه
والاضطرابات في امدادات القمح العالميه
تسعى اثيوبيا في تغيير اليتها الزراعيه
للتخلص من التبعيه للخارج وضمان امنها
الغذائي في ظل ظروف انك اقتصاديه صعبه
الاجنبي سعيد المزين للعربيه من اقليم
الاثيوبيا
عقدت الاليه الثلاثيه في السودان والسفراء
العربي اجتماعا في منزل السفير السعودي
بالخرطوم وهكذا الاجتماع على دعم جنود
العليه الثلاثيه في تسيير العمليات
السياسيه في السودان بدوره شدد السفير
السعودي بالخرطوم علي بن حسن جعفر على حرص
المملكه على الدفع كل الجهود لتحقيق
الاستقرائي في السودان
اصدر رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان قرارا بتجميد نشاط
النقابات والاتحادات المهنيه والاتحاد
العام لاصحاب العمل واعلن مجسوس السياده
في بيان تشكيل لجنه لتكوين لجان تسير
اعمال للنقابات والاتحادات المهنيه واتحاد
العمل وشمل القرار تحديد وحصر الصداقه
وحسابه نقابه داخل وخارج السودان ووضعها
تحت السيطره
اهلا بكم من جديد افاده مراسل العربيه بان
محكمه الارهاب في تونس اخذت سبيل رئيس
الحركه نهضر راشد الغنوشي
لانا دقيقه معه استمر لمده اثنتين عشره
ساعه
شيخ لا احنا خمسه قال النائب العاملي
بصديق الصور ان نتائج تحاليل برومات
البوتاسيوم التي اجريت في المانيا اظهرت
وجود الماده في 27 موقعا مختلفا في ليبيا
لصنع الخبز والحلويات واوضحها النائب
العام ان العيناجره سحبوها من كل مصانع
الدقيق والمخابز ومحال الحلويات
والمخبوزات والتي وصلت الى نحو 600 عينه
من جميعا
ماده برومات البوتاسيوم
من الدرجه الثانيه
في ليبي ايضا انفردت العربيه بمتابعه
انطلاق عمليه فرز ملفات الترشح للمناصب
السياديه المقدمه للمجلس الاعلى لدوله حيث
قد قدمت ملفات ترشح لشغل مناصب رئيس
مفوضيه الانتخابات والمصرف المركزي
ومكافحه الفساد وهيئه الرقابه الاداريه
وغيرها من عضويه مجالس الاداره في
المؤسسات العليا في البلاد
من هنا تبدا اللجنه التابعه للمجلس الاعلى
للدوله والمتخصصه في فرز وقبولي ملفات
الترشح للمناصب السياديه في فرز الملفات
التي قدمت لها خلال الاسبوع الماضي حيث
تنفرج العربيه والحدث بمتابعه عمل اللجنه
من داخل مكاتبها اكثر من 400 ملف سيكون
على اللجنه مراجعتها بالكامل بعد ان ترشح
اصحابها لشغل المناصب السياديه المخوله
للمجلس تسميتها وابرزها رئيس ديوان
المحاسبه ومحافظ المصري في المركزي ورئيس
هيئه مكافحه الفساد ورئيس هيئه الرقابه
الاداريه
حتى تاخذ وقت لان عدد الملفات كبير وخاصه
فيما يخص عضويات مكافحه الفساد وعضويه
المركزي وعضويه الاعلى المفوضيه العليا
للانتخابات بعد ان تتم عمليه الفرز يصوت
المجلس الاعلى لاختيار سبعه اسماء لكل
منصب يحولها الى مجلس النواب لاختيار
ثلاثه اسماء الذي يرجعها بدوره الى مجلس
الدوله لتسميه صاحب المنصب واعتماده بعد
النجاح في في
تنصيب النائب العام والمحكمه العليا وباقي
الخمسه ناقص السياديه باذن الله اا مع ال-
ال- الاخوه او الساده مجلس النواب
سيتم العمل معا باذن الله لانهاء هذا همم
الملف بالكامل
المناصب السياديه بدايه من التقسيمات
القبليه والجهويه لكل مرشح وصولا الى ربط
نجاح المجلسين في هذه العمليه بتوافق على
توحيد الحكوماتين مما يزيد الامر صعوبه
خصوصا بعد الخلافات الاخيره بين المجلسين
وحكومه الوحده الوطنيه
منير الاشهب طرابلس العربيه
للدور الثاني فرنسا والبرازيل وذلك بعد
فوزه على الاوروغواي
[موسيقى]
الله فريق صراحه تعرف امريكا الجنوبيه
يعني بصراحه بيلعبوا وعندهم يعني البنيه
الجسمانيه قويه رغم انكسار المكسيك ولكن
زي مارادونا
طيب الذكر
بسرعه في الالتحام غير يعني غير شوف قصير
بس انه يطلع معك بتجنن حتى
فيعني احسن طريقه معهم
[موسيقى]
تلعب بهذا الصراحه لانه همم
اخبار الرياضه حياكم الله يواجهوا المنتخب
السعودي مع فضيله الغيابات قبل مواجهه
الاخيره والحاسمه امام المكسيك الاربعاء
المقبل وعلى الرغم من استعاده الفرنسي
ايربرو رونار مدرب المنتخب خدمات اللاعب
رياض شراحيلي بعد تعافيين من الاصابه التي
حرمته من المشاركه في اول مباراتين الى
انه سيفتقد خدمات محمد البريك بسبب
الاصابه وعبد الاله المالكي الذي تلقى
بطاقتين صفراوين كان الثنائي سلمان الفرج
وياسر الشهراني تاكد غيابهم عن باقي
البطوله بدائي
وضع المدرب جلال القادري لمساته الاخيره
على تدريبات المنتخب التونسي قبل مواجهه
حامل اللقب المنتخب الفرنسي في ختام
مباريات المجموعه الرابعه ويتمسك النسور
قرطاج ببصيص الامل في التاهل الى الدوري
المقبل حيث تملكه تونس نقطه واحده حافظتها
من تعادل كان امام الدنمارك في ما خسرت في
الجوله الثانيه امام منتخب استراليا
اصبح المنتخب البرازيلي ثانيا المتاهلين
الى دوري السته عشر بعد ان تجاوز نظيره
السويسري بهدف من دون رد ضمن مباريات
المجموعه السابعه هدف البرازيل الوحيد
سجله كاسبيرو يضع في رصيده سته نقاط من
انتصارين تصدر بهماته لما تجمده سيدي
سويسرا عند ثلاث نقاط كما قد جمعتها من
فوزيه على الكاميرون في المواجهات الاولى
المباراه شهد التدخل من تقنيه حكم الفيديو
المساعد الذي الف هدفا برازيليا كان سجله
مجموعه
وقاد البديل بن صن ابو بكر منتخب بلاده
الكاميرون لتعويض التاخر امام صربيا الى
التعادل مثير بثلاثه اهداف لكل طرف في
منافسات المجموعات السابعه منتخب
الكاميرون افتتحت تسجيله اولا قبل ان يرده
منتخب صربيا بثلاثه اهداف متتاليه وفي
الشوط الثاني سجلت الكاميرون هدفين في ظرف
في دقيقتين هذه النتيجه ابقت على امال
الفريقين في التاهل قائمه حتى الجوله
المقبله
من جهه اخرى
منتخب بلاده البرتغال الى دور 16 كالت
المتاهلين بعدما سجل ثنائيه في شباك
الاوروغوايسات المجموعه الثامنه الهدف
الاول سجله فرنانديز في الدقيقه 54 وبدا
كان رونالدو من لمس الكره لكنه احتسب
للاعبي خطي الوسط الذي عاد سجل الهدف
الثاني من ركله الجزاء البرتغال رفعت
قصيده الى ست نقاط بينما بقي رصيد
اوروجواي عند نقطه واحد
[تصفيق]
وخطف منتخب غانا فوزه الاول في كاس العالم
بتغلبه على كوريا الجنوبيه بثلاثه اهداف
لهدفين تقدم بلاك ستارز بهدفين في الشوط
الاول احرزهما كل من محمد سليسو ومحمد
قدوس خلال الشوط الثاني تمكن المنتخب
الاسيوي من العوده في النتيجه في ثلاث
دقائق بهدفين سجلهما كيوسيونغ لكن محمد
قدوس اياكس امستردام عاد ليعطي المنتخب
الغني النقاط الفوز ويرفع المنتخب
الافريقي قصيده او يرفع المنتخب الافريقي
رصيده الى ثلاث نقاط في المجموعه الثامنه
ويعزز اماله الافتاء للدوري المصري
[تصفيق]
الثلاثاء تعود منافسات المجموعه الاولى
بمواجهه بين منتخب هولندا الباحث عن ضمان
بطاقته الى دور ال16 ونظيره القطري مضيف
البطوله ويتقاسم للفريق الهولندي صداره
المجموعه مع الاكوادور برصيد اربع نقاط
لكنه يتاخر بفارق الاهداف وسيكون التعادل
كافيا لهولندا لضمان التاهل رسميا للدوري
المقبل
لقد لعبنا امام فرق الكبرى مثل منتخب
السنغال بطل افريقيا وكذلك منتخب
الاكوادور الذي يعد احد افضل فرق امريكا
اللاتينيه هذه كانت مجموعه صعبه
وحاولنا ان نكون في وضع افضل لكن هذه هي
الرياضه كما تعلمون خذنا مواجهتين صعبه
ان ابقى مركزا مع المنتخب
لكن لا يزال امامي الكثير من العمل في كره
القدم تسير بطريقه جنونيه انا الان لاعب
في لكن سنرى ماذا سيحدث في الفتره المقبله
وتطلع السنغالي تكراري انجازي 2002 وبلوغ
فم النهائي للمره الثانيه في تاريخها
عندما تلاقي منتخب الاكوادور في مواجهه هي
الاولى بينهما في تاريخ النهائيات
واللقاءات الرسميه
وتشهد المجموعه الثانيه مواجهه مشتعله على
الصعيد السياسي اكثر من الرياضي بين
المنتخب بين الامريكي ونظيره الايراني
سيكون المنتخب الامريكي بحاجه للفوز
للتاهل للدور الثاني للمره الثالثه على
التوالي بين عمي 2010 و2014 وهي التي غابت
عن مونديال 2018 في روسيا في ما قد يكون
التعادل كافيه لمنتخب ايران في حال خدمتها
نتيجه انجلترا مع ويلز للوصول الى الدور
الثاني للمره الاولى في تاريخها
وفي المجموعات نفسها يلتقي منتخب انجلترا
مع منتخب ويلز في الجوله الاخيره الفريق
الانجليزي لديه اربع نقاط من مباراتين في
ما يحتل الفريق الويلزي المركز الاخير
بنقطه واحده ويجب على ويلز الفوز على
انجلترا للمره الاولى منذ عام 84 وان
يتعادل المنتخب الايراني مع نظيره
الامريكيه من اجل تاهل
ابرز اخبار الرياضه
انا الرابعه
يعني عنده خبره كبيره وعمل مع منتخبات
وايضا وصلهم الى كاس العالم واخرها 2018
المغرب همم
الطريقه الايجاز يدير فيها المنتخب انا
اشوف عقلانيه ومنطقيه
اللاعبين اللي يلعبوا معها في التصفيات
الى الان متمسك فيهم وهمم لغه الحوار معهم
همم
يعني احس انها مرتاحه لها هو كان مدرب
[موسيقى]
في حديثا للعربيه قال وزير الدوله لشؤون
الخارجيه السعودي عادل الجبير ان
المباحثات
عفوا مشاهدينا قال ان المباحثات مع اوروبا
شملت سبلت عزيزي التعاون بين السعوديه
والدول الاوروبيه في مواجهه التغير
المناخي
بحثنا ال ال الاوضاع في المنطقه
وبحثنا التعاون بين الدول الاوروبيه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه في مواجهه
التاير المناخي وفي في بحثنا ايضا كيف
تعليقات التاريخيه بين الطرفين وسبل
تعزيزها وتطويرها في كل المجالات الدول
الاوروبيه تدرك اهتمام المملكه حرس
المملكه والمبادرات اللي طرحتها المملكه
في ما يتعلق بمواجهه خير المنافي وفيما
يتعلق بالبيئه بشكل عام يقدرون مبادره
السعوديه الخضراء الشرق الاوسط الخضراء
التي طرحتها المملكه
والقمه الثانيه الذي عقدت في شرم الشيخ
مؤخرا
النشره الى العناوين
بعد اسبوعين على استبعاد ايران من هيئه
المراه وجنرال يقر بمقتل اكثر من 300 في
المضارع
اجتماع الاليه الثلاثيه والسفراء العرب
بالخرطوم والسعوديه تؤكد حرصها على
استقرار السودان
تنضم الى المؤهلين الى الدور الثاني فرنسا
والبرازيل
اشكركم حسن متابعه مشاهدينا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]